eine frage begleitet mich auf der
gesamten food journey die ich auf meinem
kanadier erleben und zwar von euch ihr
fragt mich immer und immer und immer
wieder max machst du mal ein eigenes
ressort auf und heute kommen wie der
ganzen sache einen großen schritt näher
denn hat mich angesprochen und gesagt
hey max willst du nicht mal unsere
services ausprobieren um ein restaurant
erstellen zu lassen beziehungsweise all
das erstellen zu lassen was zu einem
restaurant gehört das heißt wir sprechen
von einem logo sprechen von einer karte
gesprächen von musik in gesprächen von
der website also wirklich alles was ich
bräuchte wenn ich ein restaurant hätte
noch dazu werde ich ein zwei gerichte
kochen von der menükarte all das wird
heute stattfinden ich habe am ende des
videos noch eine ankündigung für euch
aber dazu mehr am ende des videos wir
brauchen jetzt erstmal eine idee ich
liebe heilt italienische küche es gibt
aber so viele italienische restaurant
schon und bin auch kein italiener dann
finde ich halt so was cool wie fusion
küche also dass man von verschiedenen
küchen das beste fusioniert und alles
auf eine karte schreibt problem dass so
ein konzept wirklich gut funktioniert
ist ganz schön viel arbeit also das ist
vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel das
sprengen vielleicht den rahmen eine idee
habe ich schon die hat ja auch nicht
ganz allein die hatte ich gemeinsam mit
dave erinnert euch leicht an unseren
halle 2 podcast wenn ihr unseren halle 2
podcast hört dann kennt ihr vielleicht
unsere idee einen flammkuchen laden
aufzumachen also ein restaurant welches
nur flammkuchen verkauft warum frank
rose geil flammkuchen kennen keine
jahreszeit flammkuchen sind nicht so
weit verbreitet wie pizza oder sonst war
es deshalb planen wir heute einen
flammkuchen land und das beste ist
vielmehr muss ich jetzt gerade gar nicht
wissen denn alles andere entsteht im
prozess ich würde sagen wir beginnen mit
dem logo wie wird unser flammkuchen
laden im herzen von köln aussehen also
laptop geschnappt wired.com eingegeben
und los an die arbeit ich habe mir ein
paar coole services bei fiber ausgesucht
mit denen ich jetzt die gesamte
gestaltung von unserem restaurant machen
mich zuallererst beginnen wir mal mit
dem logo dafür schalten einfach auf den
logo maker da können wir nämlich einfach
ki basiert und so ein logo erstellen
lassen jetzt müssen wir den brand namen
eingeben hier dürfen wir uns nicht zu
lange aufhalten nennen das ganze einfach
lang wochenstube ok industrie fritsch
und eine dritte ich gehe mal noch
pizzeria ein flammkuchen ist glaube ich
eine deutsche sache oder wenn ich genau
wie deshalb ein stückchen von der pizza
sind ja genau so aus wie ein stückchen
flammkuchen show me your okay dass hier
finde ich schon gar nicht verkehrt aber
das ist somit der dreidimensionalität
ist so ein bisschen viel in meinem kopf
ist so ein flammkuchen restaurant aus
dir voll simple okay da gefällt mir die
grundidee sehr gut da kann man
vielleicht darauf aufbauen wenn wir die
front ändern und alles so wenn wir jetzt
hier einmal jahre anpassen ich finde
dieses das feuer davon gefällt mir am
besten okay ich glaube ich habe meine
zwei logo entwurf fertig erika wird so
ein club mal problem habe ich relativ
natur belastung da waren ja noch diese
grillzange die habe ich weg gemacht
indem ich die einfach in die gleiche
farbe gemacht habt ihr den hintergrund
ich finde aber so für ihr belgisches
viertel und so zieren nicht sowas klien
es eigentlich am meisten
ich glaube das ist es wirklich das ist
sehr simpel weil es einfach so black &
white ist ich habe jetzt antwort und das
ist das problem
das ist das was wir gar keine feuer
farben ich will einfach nur dass wir
haben ein logo ich gehe jetzt um auch
bei und download dann ist das abgehakt
und dann geht es an die größeren
projekte logo steht zeit für den
nächsten punkt und zwar die menükarte
mindestens genauso wichtig wie ein logo
bei einem restaurant das wichtigste ist
natürlich das essen dazu kommen wir
später aber noch und ich würde sagen wir
schauen mal gemeinsam rein abbey
wo der gute herr braucht fünf tage um
das alles fertig zu stellen wir haben
zweimal die möglichkeit änderung
einzugeben druckfertig eine seite der
inhalt wird gemacht dann schreiben wir
mal eine nachricht an android
was auch nicht fehlen darf es natürlich
eine schöne website eine landingpage und
limited revisions auf fünf tage
lieferzeit ich beschreibe dem sky dieser
jetzt einfach mal was ich mir vorstelle
als website und hängen ihm ein bisschen
bildmaterial
[Musik]
also nachricht raus sagt dann fehlt uns
noch eine letzte sache und zwar musik
[Musik]
okay das was wir jetzt gerade gehörten
diese epische musik natürlich nichts für
unseren kleinen kuchen an aber ich
dachte an so etwas wie load bietet
alles klar hallo schotten plane eine
erfunden des restaurants flammkuchen
verkauft und ich brauche ein paar
entspannte lauf abc im hintergrund
laufen können der shop so erbin und
minimalistisch sein bitte seid kreativ
wenn du den sound erstellt das wäre
super wenn man ihn lupen könnte also
immer wieder nacheinander abspielen
könnte damit er durchgehend laufen kann
vielen dank liebe grüße max so wir haben
jetzt wirklich alles wenn alles gut geht
und die ergebnisse stimmen dann haben
wir eine chance wir haben ein logo wir
haben eine menükarte und wir haben sogar
musik die in unserem restaurant spielt
ich denke jetzt brauchen wir ein
bisschen geduld und dann freue ich mich
auf die ersten ergebnisse
wer weiß vielleicht passt ihr alles im
ersten anlauf aber ich bin mir sicher
ein zwei sachen müssen wir noch ändern
ich freue mich sehr und ich sehe schon
die erste antwort haben wir sogar schon
okay wenige tage später und wir haben
alles geliefert bekommen und nun seht
ihr das logo das war ja wer direkt dann
wollen wir uns mal die menükarte
anfangen auf die sehr spannend wird das
geht also 85 wird das ganze jahr sein so
ein schönes teils format die vorderseite
beziehungsweise rückseite sehr schön
clean flammkuchen stube food menü also
zweifel karte und unten sehen wir die
eigentliche karte ja okay also sieht
wirklich direkt aus wie ein laden in dem
man gerne auch mal ein zwei euro mehr
ausgibt weil man im gesamtkonzept quasi
denkt okay das ist qualitativ so auch
die karte ist qualitativ und das ist
hier 100 prozent gegeben dass flanken
stube logo oben drauf ankommt wie sehr
sehr gut hier finde ich auch schön
gelöst so mit den einzelnen
bestandteilen wenn man einen eigenen
flammkuchen baut das ist also die
kleinen icons von den hier bei dem obst
gemüse oder sowas sind wenn ich diese
karte in einem laden sehen würde sind
wir wirklich schon positiv auffallen das
ist nicht nur eine neue karte sondern
dies so aufteilen und gut also damit bin
ich zehn von zehn tepic gucken wir mal
nach der musik wie ihr wisst habe ich
mir einen lauf beat für den hintergrund
gewünscht einfach weiter meine videos
läuft immer lauter musik finden auch in
das ladenkonzept du dieses
minimalistische urbane passt das auch
folgen und rein gehören mir ein
gefühl hier entspannt fühlt ihr euch
lassen wir jetzt so weiter laufen für
euch es ist auf jeden fall so weit so
das passt zu dem laden was wird so
richtig so laid back und man kommt hin
ist was gutes schnelles und im
hintergrund läuft diese musik ich meine
ihr werdet ihr gleich eine idee von dem
laden bekommen ich habe mich für morgen
etwas besonderes geplant dann werde in
den sommer auf jeden fall auch noch mal
eine sache fehlt noch eine website wir
gucken uns das ganze an auch die website
die texte sind natürlich nicht final
also wir haben einfach irgendwas zu
sagen mit langen hosen zum beispiel ja
nicht auf belgien egal wir haben das
logo wieder oben welches sehr gepflegt
daher kommt das bildmaterial wurden
wirklich sehr gut integriert ich finde
es wirklich schön bieten eine viel zeit
hatte ich zu meiner flanken und
neuinterpretationen an noch mein neues
youtube-video eingebaut wir wissen was
zu mehr ist mein laden ist klar haben
wir das menü mit demo bildern auch hier
wieder sehr smart gelöst die haben sich
gar nicht gesprochen aber beide intuitiv
eine sehr gute lösung gefunden grace
klar und sehr schön da unten dann auch
zur diese location von dem laden die
flammen lampenstube also ich muss sagen
wenn ich das so sehe jetzt wird das
alles existiert ich finde es schade dass
es den laden nicht gibt weil das ist ja
alles und point und das sind so kurzer
zeit das ist wirklich will damit würde
ich sagen haben wir alles was wir
brauchen um unser gedanken experiment
durchzuführen ich werde morgen die
flammen puppenstube für einen tag hier
bei uns im büro zum leben erwecken und
ich würde sagen wir sehen uns genau
dafür wieder und damit herzlich
willkommen der flammkuchen studie ich
finde wirklich die karte hier als t
shirt an mir das logo und auch das alles
ist schon so dass ich jetzt schon an
wieso mein eigenes baby aber ist
existiert nur in meinem kopf das tut mir
sehr leid ich habe hier die zutaten für
einen klassischen elsässer flammkuchen
den ich exemplarisch für uns backen
rechte zu hause hatte ich diesen tag
vorbereitet ihr zaubern uns jetzt einen
leckeren proben flanken er hat doch mal
der zwischenzeit ein blick auf die karte
gibt hier noch einige andere haben
gehofft hier ist natürlich für den
klassiker entschieden monolog ich sehe
die karte hat zum ersten mal was soll
ich sagen aber das sieht so dass hier
viel aus ich finde sieht nicht nur gut
aus sondern es sieht aus als wäre das
hier ein kranker laden also wirklich
hingehen will weil er so krasser ist als
andere aber zurück zum teig ich hoffe
der rest ich jetzt schön ausrollen ich
muss sagen die wartezeit jetzt hier über
die am restaurant die gäste auch ein
bisschen zur und ihm übrig
flammkuchen sollte eigentlich schnell
gehen würde das ist nicht mein anspruch
über die flammkuchen stube aber man
sieht auf jeden fall bombay handmade so
wir wählen wir uns auch blech
gegeben auf die creme fraiche das rote
zwiebeln speck den rest erledigt schon
der ofen
[Musik]
ich muss sagen ich finde es sieht so
richtig schön helfer aus der erste
bissen von einem flammkuchen stube
flammen punkten
sein lieblingsgericht so einfach und man
kann einiges falsch machen sie ja du
musst bewerten jakob
und reis raten du hast ja jetzt nicht
richtig drauf geguckt habe wie viel euro
ist er den wert von 50
8 euro in der planung buchungstool weil
noch lang kuchen der muss so heike teuer
sind evans bauten auch du musst
probieren
ich weiß also kennen so frisches essen
schmeckt immer lecker das schmeckt auch
so wenn du dich auch so richtig geil
originals lampen also lasst den
geschmack richtig gut getroffen finde
ich bei höheren schule nicht zuletzt
wegen dem rating auf überzeugt so
schnell ist sie also entstanden die
flammkuchen studie ich bin wirklich
überrascht und unfassbar hätte wie das
ganze im endeffekt zusammengekommen ist
von a bis z wirklich alles ist frisch
ist cool und hat mir einmal mehr gezeigt
dass das auf jeden fall ein traum ist
den ich mir eines tages verwirklichen
möchte dass sie eines tages irgendwann
mal einen kleinen eigenen laden haben ob
es dann die flanke studie ist sei mal
dahin gestellt aber ich würde sagen
damit dieses ziel ein bisschen
greifbarer wird sage ich jetzt einfach
mal bei zwei millionen abonnenten mache
ich meinen eigenen laden auf jetzt ist
es jetzt habe ich mal gesagt ich bin
ernsthaft das hat sehr viel spaß gemacht
ich hoffe ihr hattet auch spaß mit dem
video vielen dank noch mal an feiert sie
das ganze überhaupt erst möglich gemacht
haben website menü sonst was hätte ich
gar nicht alleine hinbekommen so im
rahmen von einem video deshalb
verwirklichen kuder fall um zu zeigen
was möglich ist danke fürs zu sehen und
bis zum nächsten mal rein und ich jetzt
in urlaub eric auch